[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima Monday  night - brought us the Bachelorette men  tell all and the special did not  disappoint with major moments from  Demario that's called a side chick a big  discussion on racism with Lee  I don't like racism at all it bothers me  and fan favorite Dean getting his  goodbye with Rachel that ultimately just  led me to being much more heartbroken  I'm sorry  that's that's how you feel now everybody  was wondering how much the bachelor in  paradise scandal would be brought up  during the Bachelorette mento all  special the answer is not much save for  this one reference from Chris Harrison  himself I have it on tape I do the  Bachelorette Season finale airs Monday  August 7th on ABC and who do you guys  think Rachel will pick let me know over  on Twitter  [Music]  you